[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire pour
débattre discuter et réfléchir sur les
grands enjeux qui font l'actualité
le thème de ce soir la sensibilisation
aux gestes et notamment le sida en cette
période sanitaires toujours aussi est
nécessaire et importante ces derniers
mois à la cofidis nymphes et omniprésent
quand on parle de santé mais les autres
maladies continuent de circuler
l'épidémie de coronavirus a aussi un
impact très négatif sur l'épidémie de
vih
les associations et acteurs tirent la
sonnette d'alarmé le nombre de
dépistages a diminué de près de 60 %
entre février et avril 2020 est ce lié à
un manque de sensibilisation va en
parler pendant ces prochaines minutes
avec nos deux invités germandrée bonsoir
vous êtes le directeur de la chaire
prévention de l'association basée à
saint quentin en yvelines et bastien
vibert bonsoir vous êtes le responsable
du programme vih aux crips le centre
régional d'information et de prévention
du sida pour la santé des jeunes
alors je le disais dans les titres le
nombre de dépistages a diminué de près
de 60% lors du premier confinement
jérôme andré ce que c'est un chiffre
inquiétant mais archi qui est très
inquiétant parce qu'on se rend compte
qu'on a un retard de dépistage et qui
dit retard de dépistage dit aussi que
l'épidémie qui est caché on estime entre
20 et 80 mille personnes qui s'ignorent
ne va pas être dépistées donc
correctement cette année donc on voit en
moyenne entre 6 et 7000 personnes chaque
année
découvrent leur sérologie mais pour
qu'ils puissent découvrir leur sérologie
encore faut-il qu'il y ait des actions
de dépistage et que le dépistage ne
perdent pas donc de sa force
et là en l'occurrence vous le disiez 65
cent des gens n'ont pas été dépistées on
peut s'attendre effectivement à ce que
plus de 60% des gens ne se découvre pas
leur séropositivité et continuent de
contaminer d'autres personnes
et c'est en ça ou c'est effectivement
très inquiétant et danser 60 % s'ils
sont les hommes qui se font le moins des
pistes et 66%
mais oui parce qu'on va
lité les femmes prennent plus soin
d'elle on le voit c'est la majorité des
cas sur l'ensemble donc de la santé en
france
les femmes sont plus enclins à aller se
faire dépister et l'a donc du coup le
vih ne n'échappe pas à cette règle
les hommes vont moins facilement au
dépistage hf prévention on a des
programmes doubt reach est à dire qu'on
va vers les gens pour pouvoir donc les
dépister et en l'occurrence on aime bien
choper des garçons on aime bien chauffé
les hommes parce qu'effectivement ce
sont souvent eux qui ont un retard au
dépistage mais qui du coup à cause de la
qu'ovide va poser un vrai problème pour
les années futures
bastian gibert de vendre confinement on
était chez nous donc potentiellement il
y avait moins de comportements à risque
on aura donc une une sérologie positive
plus importante pour l'année 2000 21 ou
finalement ces chiffres seront plus bas
mais s'expose et jérôme on a en moyenne
trois ans et demi entre une
contamination est couvert d'une
compétitivité
donc on va on va avoir son nom c'est ce
que voit on n'a pas de certitudes et m'a
quand même très forts doutes là dessus
on va avoir une hausse des découvertes
de séropositivité
mais la question c'est est ce qu'on va
voir une hausse très tardive où nous
pousse précoce et où l'en but on est
parti pour une couche tard dit est-ce
qu'il ya d'autres facteurs qui peuvent
expliquer qu'on n'a pas été se faire
dépister
on a tellement parlé de la colite qu'on
a eu peur que de ça finalement c'est
également de préciser c'est que le
confinement n'a pas forcément été un
confinement total
les gens ont continué d'avoir des
rapports sexuels et ils ont continué
aussi à avoir des comportements
sexuelles extraconjugales
le confinement n'a rien arrêté donc au
contraire les gens ont vécu une nouvelle
sexualité dans la clandestinité et donc
on le voit parce qu'on a redéployé les
dépistages
à partir donc du mois de juin jusqu'au
nouveau confinement donc 2 octobre et on
l'a vu on a des nouvelles prises de
risques on a à la fois des nouveaux
comportements de
on qui ont pris plus de risques sexuels
donc ils n'ont pas mis de préservatifs
et qu ils ne se sont pas protégés
beaucoup plus de manière beaucoup plus
importante qu'avant et a contrario on a
des gens qui n'ont pas eu de sexualité
du tout donc en réalité les extrêmes se
sont créés et là où effectivement avec
bastien au niveau de la région ile de
france
on craint effectivement une reprise des
infections sexuellement transmissibles
et notamment du vih sida
bastien gilbert justement aussi on a
noté une baisse de la délivrance des
médicaments utilisés en prophylaxie
pré-exposition sa renforcer aussi les
risques on sait pas protégés de cette
manière là non plus le film en ouverture
de deux prêtent donc de traitement avant
l'exposition pour les personnes servies
pour les protéger du vih c'est aussi
parce que on sait aujourd'hui que ça
fait partie des outils prévention ou
même quelques panneaux relatifs au même
titre que dépistage au même titre que le
traitement pour les personnes
séropositives dont on a réellement du
souci rr 1 trappage à faire et ce que
disent et jaune sur le dépistage il
aussi bas que je la prenne
il faut rattraper le retard il va
falloir faire un gros focus aussi bien à
part des associations mais aussi écoles
publiques il faut pour vous accompagner
et justement germandrée ministre de la
santé via véran annoncé hier que les
médecins libéraux pourraient bientôt
initiés directement ce fameux traitement
préventif
c'est une avancée alors c'est une
avancée qui n'était à attendre donc la
coved n'a rien empêché mais en tous les
cas ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il faut que
les gens prennent conscience que plus
que jamais il faut faire attention à sa
santé et y compris sa santé sexuelle et
par rapport à ça donc il ya des tas
d'initiatives qui font que la lutte
contre le sida toujours été précurseur
de ça qu'on parle de dépistage
aujourd'hui vous rendez compte on a les
fameuses autotests donc qui sont
proposés en pharmacie une vingtaine
d'euros
et puis des associations comme la nôtre
plus de 8
il ôte aux tests sont diffusés
gratuitement et notamment grâce à
l'engagement de valérie pécresse
notamment grâce à ile de france sans
sida elle a souhaité mettre à
disposition de structures comme la nôtre
ces fameuses auto test de dépistage
autotests qui permettent de rattraper
justement ce retard de dépistage puisque
nous avons la possibilité d'envoyer par
la poste directement aux gens lors des
confinement cette solution là on
travaille également à h/f prévention à
une solution d'intelligence artificielle
notamment avec la région ile de france
mais pas seulement le laboratoire gilead
on est en train de d'innover de produire
une intelligence artificielle qui
permettra au kilomètre zéro d'à la fois
de discuter avec les gens mais aussi
d'envoyer des auto test de dépistage par
la poste ou dans des hamacs the doc ou
d'autres solutions donc on le voit il ya
une vraie nécessité à déployer des
solutions qui sont des solutions
innovantes pour que les gens puissent
avoir la possibilité à la fois de se
protéger mais aussi de se dépister et
puis on ne sait encore aujourd'hui des
gens qui sont dépistés il ya la
prévention le dépistage et puis il y as
derrière le côté médicaments des gens
qui sont aujourd'hui traités vont
pouvoir devenir en charge virale
indétectable et devenir non contaminants
s'il n'y avait pas eu de retard au
dépistage
on aurait pu mettre des gens ce
traitement est aujourd'hui on le sait on
aurait pu en protéger beaucoup plus que
ça parce que les traitements permettent
effectivement de pouvoir donc est
indétectable et donc non contaminants
donc vous voyez la chaîne s'est brisé
cette année on a une double sanction
parce qu'on n'a pas les chiffres de
l'année dernière parce que je suis d
président et les laboratoires sont je
suis vice présent d'un corps et vie une
coordination régionale en ile de france
sud et nos techniciennes et techniciens
d'études cliniques ont dû travailler sur
la copie parce qu'on à réaxer le
personnel soignant sur les lacs au vide
et c'est bien normal mais du coup pour
le vih et un impact majeur qu'on n'a pas
en amont n'a effectivement pas les
chiffres donc du dépistage de l'année
dernière on ne sait pas en avi
vu on va naviguer en plus encore a vu
cette année parce qu'on n'aura pas des
chiffres de 2020 il ya de fortes chances
qu'on n'est pas non plus les chiffres de
et si vous avez bien écouter ce qu'a dit
bastien on a déjà un retard de trois ans
et demi sur les prises en charge des
personnes séropositives puisqu'on
découvre les gens trois ans et demi
après autant dire que là on se prend
quasiment presque 5 à 6 ans dans la vue
dans la lutte contre le sida et ça va
être juste dramatique et justement vous
disiez il ya aussi une certaine
responsabilité à prendre soi-même
bastien vibert parmi les missions du
crips il y à celle des actions dans les
milieux scolaires et les structures
accueillant des publics vulnérables
est-ce que vous pouvez toujours
sensibilisés où il est plus dur pour
vous de rentrée dans les établissements
scolaires et sachant qu'ils ont été
confinés fermé en mars aussi alors pour
le moment tout va bien c'est à dire peut
entrer nos établissements avec
évidemment l'accord des 17 ans donc ça
il n'y a pas de souci moi ce que votre
question est intéressante parce que on
peut y aller il va passer souvent il ya
une loi qui date et à quelques années
qui dit que en gros on va avoir trois
séances éducation à la sexualité dans
les écoles chaque année aujourd'hui la
région des finances pour ça donc c'est
très bien je vous paie ses passions
devant la base à la région ça serait
drôle de l'état donc ce qu'on voudrait
aujourd'hui c'est que les élèves ne
soient pas en perte de change de prendre
soin d'eux et donc on est la possibilité
financière de tenir l'engagement légal
de faire ces trois séances aujourd'hui
on la pâte qu'on a passé on a passé la
seule financement et c'est bien dommage
parce que ça empêche les jeunes d'être
outillés pour l'avenir et par exemple
pour les 1/2 dépistage c'est se dire à
18 19 20 en hd en ville mais pas de
piste et je sais pourquoi j'ai envie de
le faire et c'est un essai un acteur
banal finale et je trouve que nolan ne
pas tenir ses engagements des trois
séances bah c'est simplement un énorme
problème de santé publique et il faut
que l'état prenne ses responsabilités
est ce qu'on ne sait pas aussi trop
habitués à ce virus finalement on sait
qu'à le sidaction chaque année ça
revient mais on ne voit pas il est
invisible pour certains germandrée si je
peux me permettre
compléter les propos de bastien parce
qu'il ya un vrai travail qui est fait
entre la cheffe prévention et le crips
ile de france c'est à dire que nous nous
sommes dans la continuité de service ils
ont effectivement le rôle de faire de la
prévention et de la promotion de la
santé auprès donc des publics les plus
jeunes derrière nous on les récupère en
université et quand on l'est des pistes
en université on se rend compte
effectivement qu'aujourd'hui 1 63% des
gens qu'on va dépister rendez vous
compte 1 63% des gens qui ont des pistes
dans les universités sont séropositifs
ce qui veut donc dire que quand on est
dans un centre de dépistage classique on
est à 0 2 dans le milieu gay on est à
0,6 on est à 1 % de plus ce qui prouve
bien que les trois séances d'information
parents qui sont en plus financé par la
région ile de france parce qu'on est
dans une région qui est responsable
qui a envie on va effectivement de faire
des choses pour ces jeunes mais même là
on voit que ce n'est pas suffisant
donc on a besoin de plus et on le sent
aujourd'hui la banalisation ce n'est pas
vraiment une banalisation c'est aussi
parce qu'on ne meurt plus du sida ben on
est effectivement dans une maladie qui
est une maladie chronique
le fait de ne plus mourir du vih fait
que les gens s'en désintéressent et
malheureusement chaque année on vient
sur le plateau de tv 78 en disant que
c'est important de rappeler les chiffres
c'est important de se faire dépister
c'est important de faire que de
continuer à prendre soin de soi on voit
s'il ya beaucoup de pathologies qui
souffre effectivement de ce manque
d'intérêt mais plus que jamais on se
rend compte que oui effectivement ça
n'arrive pas qu'aux autres
mais pour le coup quand on est dépisté
parachève prévention dans les
universités centres commerciaux au coeur
de cité ou dans les lieux de rencontres
extérieures extérieur parking forêt aire
d'autoroute
en moyenne on dépiste 2% sur 16000 sont
séropositifs donc oui il ya un vrai
problème et on se rend bien compte on
est le premier des pisteurs
d'ile-de-france un haut niveau des chefs
prévention malheureusement on est devenu
le premier et ça nous pose un problème
de voir que sur seize mille dépistages 2
% vont effectivement donc être
séropositif bassin vibert quand vous
rencontrez les jeunes
personnes vulnérables ou les scolaires
est ce que vous avez à faire encore à
des idées reçues des méconnaissances il
ya une étude qui a été faite alors c'est
pas chez nous mais c'est chez nos amis
belges 23 % des gens qui ont répondu à
la question ignore que les pénétrations
son préservatif sont les pratiques
sexuelles les plus risqués est ce que la
situation similaire en france on en est
encore sur des idées reçues des clichés
parfois on est complètement jeunes et
clichés on a un livre l'information qui
est plus bas à 10 ans voit la cci n'a
pas manqué du sidaction qui le
démontrent on a un revenu de la
formation il faut que nous en apprennent
aux responsabilités et c'est bien pour
ça que l'on dit qu'il faut faire c'est
trois séances à chaque à chaque année
scolaire
sinon on aura un livre l'information ne
sera plus bas et et ses idées reçues
elles sont problématiques parce que ne
pas savoir s'il ya pas de conséquences
bon ben c'est une erreur mais ça serait
pas si grave
mais reprendre je vous dis juste avant
c'est ne pas savoir c'est ne pas laisser
les pistes et ne pas savoir c'est avoir
des comportements qui expose au vih
et c'est là où les idées reçues à son
dramatique parce qu'elle expose d'après
as des as des as des pratiques de santé
donc oui oui c'est on a des niveaux de
son prénom comparable germandrée ce
qu'il faut chercher à innover
quand on sensibilise on pense aux vireux
soir on pense à beaucoup de gérer et
d'ailleurs télé 70 et est souvent venu
voir on a effectivement les gaines
'changer comme vireux soir un virus war
2 qui continue de tourner donc ça c'est
plutôt c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
on a effectivement aussi dont contrat
cette somme bac parce qu'on s'est
beaucoup penché sur la contraception et
puis on a un outil qui est formidable
qui est l'application tubes pour trouver
des préservatifs et des lieux de
dépistage partout en france c'est une
application qui aujourd'hui réuni plus
de 500 mille personnes
cinq cent mille personnes qui
l'utilisent régulièrement au moins une
fois donc par semaine pour trouver des
préservatifs mais surtout pour trouver
des lieux de dépistage et puis donc
c'est une application qu'on est en train
de faire évoluer donc on l'a déjà fait
évoluer sur la santé sexuelle meillard
des nouveautés pour 2000
21 puisque effectivement on rentre dans
la sixième année donc de tubes donc
c'est normal de continuer à innover
on continue à parler de prévention et
puis on à l'innovation avec donc cette
nouvelle intelligence artificielle qui
va sortir l'année prochaine ou là vous
pourrez avoir une conversation que ce
soit sur une enceinte
google avec sa ou d'autres ou
directement sur votre téléphone
directement en application et puis si
l'intelligence artificielle détecte
qu'il y à une nécessité donc de vous
donner des informations des conseils et
puis de vous proposer un dépistage on
pourra vous donner donc des informations
de centres de dépistage ou même vous
envoyer immédiatement donc un autotest
parce que pour le coup ça permettra une
file et de pouvoir donc vous prévenir
est vraiment d'avoir une action globale
c'est c'est vraiment quelque chose qu'on
déploie sur l'ensemble donc des régions
beaucoup de régions comme la région ile
de france
on souhaitait donc s'associer à chef
prévention dans cette démarche pour
pouvoir offrir aux citoyens parce qu'il
s'agit de ça donc d'offrir aux citoyens
donc la possibilité de se dépister aussi
chez soi au kilomètre zéro parce qu'il
ya une vraie nécessité d'innover
on n'innove pas n'importe comment faut
que ça réponde à des bois à des vrais
besoins à des besoins concrets qui sont
mesurées effectivement on prend le temps
à chaque prévention d'être un véritable
laboratoire d'innovation et on continue
même si on est des enfants de saint
quentin et que le siège est à 50 ans nés
en yvelines et on en est fier on est un
territoire d'innovation et bien on
continue à rayonner sur l'ensemble donc
du territoire français bastien vibert
vous aussi
en particulier les milieux scolaires on
sait que c'est là où la première
éducation à la sexualité peut se faire
on innove aussi on s'adapte al
à l'époque il ya vingt ans c'était juste
expliquer parfois comment mettre un
préservatif etc ans
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on va plus loin où
il y à une barrière liée peut-être au
tabou aussi de la sexualité quand on
parle à des enfants quand 11 12 ans
alors je suis un petit aparté mais entre
java sur tube
moi je j'aime beaucoup ce applications
et je trouvais ça important de la
télécharger
parce qu'on parle beaucoup
téléchargement ce moment de deux matchs
locaux vides mais il faut aussi faux que
voilà faut télécharger tube c'est hyper
important
et s'il prend soin de ses abords les
formations prennent soin notamment sur
son portable pour répondre à votre
question
aujourd'hui les animations en scolaire
elles sont très centrée sur les
compétences psychosociales c'est à dire
que on va pas forcément parler des
risques mais on va entrer sur une vache
à lait chez le jeune hopper d'animation
et on va laisser s'exprimer ça qu'on va
par une démarche verticale de voilà je
dois qu'on sait que ça ne marche pas
mais on va le on va le essayé de lui
apporter des outils et que lui les
prennent en charge
et c'est une vraie démarche qui est
totalement différente par rapport à
avant où on disait ma voici la vérité tu
dois apprendre
basta là on le laisse s'exprimer et on
essaie du luthier pour l'avenir pour que
et c'est ça qui le but final pour que la
personne puisse derrière antti grandi
adapter sa prévention adaptées sa vie à
ces pratiques à ses envies ès qualité de
vie une vérité qui est vraiment réel et
sérieux c'est à dire qu' il n'y a pas
une prévention
il y a des préventions et en fait vous
avez une prévention à chaque moment de
votre vie et la prévention doit être
adaptée et adaptable en fonction de vos
envies vos besoins et du moment donc de
votre vie vous n'avez pas la même
prévention donc et donc on est obligé
maintenant de faire de sur mesure à
chaque prévention depuis 2004 on fait du
sur mesure et on en est
hier parce que pour le coup il faut
adapter la prévention en fonction des
gens il c'est à dire qu'il n'y a pas de
discours donc donc comme dit sébastien
il n'y a pas une vérité il ya plein de
vérité mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'il faut que les gens prennent
soin d'eux trouvent les outils adaptés
en téléchargeant tubes mais pas
seulement et puis effectivement arrive à
avoir la connaissance de leur statut
sérologique parce qu'encore une fois il
n'ya rien de pire que l'ignorance et en
parlant donc d'ignorance c'est pour ça
qu'à chef prévention état et partenaires
également d'une autre structure pour
laquelle je travaille à paris sorbonne
universités qu'est l'université des
patients parce qu'il est important pour
nous que les patients qui sont
effectivement personne séropositive mais
pas seulement on accueille effectivement
d'autres patients dans d'autres
pathologies puissent s'informer sur leur
pathologie et aussi prendre le pouvoir
au niveau décisionnaire dans les
structures et les instances de santé
publique et on a à coeur avec bar siens
parce que on fait avec avec bastien
partie du même corps et vie le corps et
vie ile de france sud on a à coeur que
les patients soient représentés aussi
auprès donc des pouvoirs publics parce
que on ne fait pas cent les gens ont
fait avec les gens et pour les gens et
est-ce qu'on peut rappeler alors à quel
moment il faut aller se faire dépister
à partir du moment où vous imaginez
avoir pris un risque et minimum une fois
par an pour les personnes
hétérosexuelles c'est bien de faire donc
son dépistage y compris pour les couples
moi je dis souvent c'est un truc de
couple que d'aller faire alors pas en ce
moment un resto un ciné un dépistage
mais sinon entend donc de qu'ovide c'est
un peu compliqué mais pour le coup c'est
aussi un truc de couple ne pas imaginer
que dans son couple quand on a arrêté le
préservatif
la personne qui est temps que dans votre
couple ne puisse pas effectivement donc
aller voir ailleurs et pour le coup ça
veut pas dire qu'ils vont pas se faire
confiance mais un petit dépistage ça
mange ça permet tout vérifier exactement
c'est justement
la peur n'évite pas le con le contrôle
ou le toit la confiance ne dit pas le
contrôle et justement à les images du
verre c'est juste que ce que disaient
les journaux c'est très intéressant
parce que c'est se faire dépister
ça doit de ça doit être banalisé où je
n'y a pas de charge morale au dépistage
ça qui est important c'est pas parce
qu'on fait dépister que hausse non c'est
sûr difficile et c'est positif c'est
bien c'est un acte qui est qui et
prendre soin de soi on dit beaucoup
faire du sport c'est bien on dit
beaucoup
stefan zingg c'est bien mais se faire
dépister c'est bien aussi et c'est ici
il faut il faut dire aux personnes qui
sont dépistés que c'est un acte chouette
je sais pas un acte moralement
répréhensible ou liane charge morale
quand on se fait dépister on a accueilli
très positivement la cli convenablement
on a le temps de parler de soi on
connaît son statut
on adapte sa prévention et c'est ça d'où
est ce cet acte là ils vont être
valorisés
c'est vraiment important je pense on a
beaucoup parlé des jeunes depuis le
début ce que c'est vrai on s'est souvent
le premier public on veut sensibiliser
voilà exactement mais on disait il ya 65
% ce sont des hommes qui découvrent leur
séropositivité l 21 1% ont 50 ans et
plus oui est ce que ce sont des gens qui
se sont contaminées dans les trois ans
ou qui ont eu un tabou c'est à dire
qu'il y à 2 h charnière il ya les moins
de 25 ans et on comprend bien pourquoi
parce qu'on est jeune on en profite
c'est et il ya aussi la charnière des
plus de 45 ans c'est un âge charnière
que nous on avait détecté il ya
plusieurs années
hf prévention qu'on avait fait remonter
à la dgs à la direction générale de la
santé et à l'eau et metz en fait il
s'agit de la charnière des plus de 45
ans qui à un moment donné de leur vie
vont avoir un changement de vie au
moment où ils vont avoir les enfants qui
ont grandi et où ils vont avoir aussi
donc les crédits maisons qui sont
changés et c est et où là du coup ils
nous font une sorte de ce que certains
appellent la crise de la quarantaine
en réalité ce changement de comportement
quand ils n'ont pas mis par exemple pour
les hommes le préservatif avec leur
femme ou la femme le préservatif avec
les hommes
donc il ya plus de préservatifs depuis
des années dans leur couple
quand ils vont effectivement voir
ailleurs ou avoir d'autres aventures ils
vont pas remettre effectivement par
degré dans cette habitude exactement et
là on est dans des prises de risque en
se disant bas le sida c'est chez les
jeunes tout comme on entendait à
l'époque le sida c'est chez les gays
mais donc effectivement cette période de
plus de 45 ans et c'est pour ça qu'on
est donc nous dans des programmes de
lieux de rencontres extra mais aussi par
king for aires d'autoroutes ou encore
universités centres commerciaux car de
citer les universités on imagine bien
pourquoi les centres commerciaux et les
choeurs de citer on imagine beaucoup
moins mais c'est effectivement aussi
pour toucher les plus de 45 ans parce
qu'il ya une vraie nécessité a donc
vérifié mais quoi qu'il en soit les gens
devraient se dire que peu importe son
âge c'est pas mal de faire vérifier dès
de connaître son statut sérologique
régulièrement
et justement cette question des
personnes séropositives vieillissante
est considérée comme une priorité dans
le plan pour une île de france sans sida
on va terminer vous donner la parole à
chacun d'entre vous pendant une petite
minute
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait mettre en place
aujourd'hui pour que ça revienne un
petit peu au coeur des réflexions public
mais surtout des réflexions personnelles
je crois que l'espace médiatique est
clairement saturé aujourd'hui par la
candide donc on ne peut pas
effectivement avoir un 1er décembre
comme on les a connus les années
précédentes ce qui est sûr c'est que les
acteurs doivent rester mobilité enfin ne
doivent rester mobilisés et on voit la
dgs et les agences régionales de santé
continuent à devrait donc dans ce schéma
là quand la co vide sera pas c'est parce
que il y aura un déconfinement et les
choses reviendront probablement un
niveau antérieur
on aura la possibilité effectivement de
redoubler d'efforts aujourd'hui ce qui
est sûr c'est que les pouvoirs publics
maintiennent les structures telles que
la nôtre
pareil pour le creps ile-de-france de
manière à ce que dès qu'il ya
réouverture on continue et on lance donc
des programmes de redé pistage et de re
prévention si on peut appeler ça comme
ça donc voir il faut juste que les gens
seraient sont mobilisés et que l'on
perde pas donc la foi et du côté du crif
ce alors qu'est ce que vous souhaiteriez
remettre en place on a vu faire plus de
sensibilisation dans les établissements
scolaires mais j'imagine que vous
regorger d'idées de volonté aussi de ce
côté là je pense que je fais et jaune
sur le parcours lycées universités
il est vachement important et ce qui
serait je pense important ça serait
facile et la demande de dépistage et
rapprocher l'offre des personnes
faciliter la demande
ça veut dire outiller les personnes pour
qui elles puissent aller faire un géant
veut faire les faire un test donc
faciliter leur envie d'aller faire un
test mais c'est à vous d'avoir envie
encore faut-il que les offreurs mais
c'est comme comme h f
comme hachette prévention puisse y faire
leur mue faire sur leur axe pont est ce
que disait je roule sur facilité enfin
rapprocher l'offre c'est-à-dire envoyés
et les soutes est adulte il souhaite au
plus près des lieux de vie
c'est absolument prioritaire c'est comme
nous on en a vite dans la vie courante
savent qu'on aime bien quand nos
magasins sont ouverts et sympathique you
on aime bien vous quand on nous livre
lendemain nos produits etc là c'est
pareil c'est faciliter l'offre est ce
que fait le chef c'est extrêmement
intéressant parce que nous ayons sassou
sy complètement à ses basques ce qui est
fait c'est que l'offre
voilà près possible des personnes hélas
plus facilité possible et donc on espère
que le public poussera jeu-concours jeu
suite au déconfinement on soit très
massif sur cet effort qui sera fait
parce qu'il a absolument prioritaire
sinon on va avoir des chiffres qui vont
remonter enfin on aura dit qu'ils vont
remonter mais il faut soit la plus
faible
on va conclure l'émission sur ces mots
merci à tous les deux d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
les différents sites internet pour
s'informer se rassurer ou échanger sur
la question du vih se sont affichées
tout au long de l'émission
cette émission est quant à elle terminé
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un nouveau numéro
[Musique]